today I'm going to demonstrate how to
program a remote for a 2012 Honda
Ridgeline this programming procedure
also works on a bit of a bunch of the
older models Hondas might not work for
all of them so just be advised now what
you're going to want to do is start with
the door closed and take your key
stick the key in the ignition you're
going to turn to the on position and hit
either lock or unlock one time
you're going to repeat this process
three to four times
and you will hear the door locks cycle
now once the door locks have cycled hit
lock or unlock one more time
you will hear the door lock Cycle One
More Time
from here on the remote has been
programmed
the next step is to turn the ignition
off to exit programming mode
now the remote will work
locker and lock
hope this helps